he'll be telling us about interaction
and distributed private learning so this
is a joint work with Adam Smith my PT
advisor and geology Panther is supposed
to be sitting right here the title of
the talk is interaction necessary for
distributed private learning I can
really give this talk in two seconds
which is
my name so I should I have an obligation
to spend more time on this so let's do
that so yeah so in this talk what I'm
going to show you is that if you have a
distributed learning problem then we'll
try to look at protocols which are
completely parallel and what can they
achieve and we will also show some
impulse affinity results which can which
basically will show that certain
problems we cannot solve with give a
bunch of devices each device and set at
a sample and then the server with the
devices are communicating to and that's
producing a model this is the general
setup of distributed learning will put
privacy on top of it and I will just say
in a bit what I mean by that is here
the structure up to this top the first
part I will tell you about the
guarantees basically both the upper and
the lower bounds which will kind of give
you some motivation to listen my second
part of the talk the algorithms if
you're not motivated you can leave the
top in the first part yeah and the third
part basically says moaning
impossibility results so the result
which are representing is from 2017
there has been some work after that
which I was kind of a Leo too but
they're not getting to the details of
those top results some of the our lower
bounds have been kind of super seat
advice in your lower boots which I'll
mention in a bit ok so distributed
machine learning in a traditional
machine learning setup you have a data
set the new trainer model order
classifier in a distributed set of what
you have your bunch of devices those are
in completely different geographical
locations and they're connecting to a
server and producing a model this raises
both algorithmic and engineering
challenges from an algorithmic
standpoint you understand that you have
to end up being the device get that
result and there is some level of
interaction from engineering standpoint
each of this communication is roughly in
milliseconds if you try to kind of have
this kind of setup I've been told that
this each of this kind of pinging the
device and getting information back is
roughly in minutes against motorboats
when you are pinging a device to get
some information you are not even sure
if the device is online to give you that
information
so interaction causes both algorithmic
and design challenges for distributed
learning so I see where things go from
here
in the context of privacy this slide is
mostly boilerplate but still I will kind
of emphasize on this just because the
first talk of the session and also just
to kind of emphasize what exactly is a
model I'm working with you a bunch of
devices the devices are connected to
that server they're producing some
result in a typical differential privacy
setup you will have like if that person
looks at the model should know
be able to figure out what the exact
data sample was or get any information
of the data sample the dataset here
along with that will you would assume
that Latimer city can actually look at
the channel or actually sit at the
server in particular it can look at the
communication from the device to the
server and still should not be able to
decide which data sample the device had
this is essentially directing us to
local differential privacy so
this tougher we'll be focusing on local
differential privacy so the motion of
differential privacy will be local
differential privacy in particular in
this definition the complete transcript
of communication with the device will be
epsilon local differentially flavored
and as pointed out by Adam this is
slightly different from what John was
mentioning in this talk so here I have
the complete transcript to be epsilon
differentially private
so if you do learning from sensitive
data people have spent a lot of time on
balancing their utility privacy
trade-offs in this talk I'll try to
motivate there is another aspect you
have to kind of balance the trade-off
width probably as important as the other
two if you want to deploy them in
practice that is the interaction with
the devices so you forget the rest of
the talk
remembering this picture is probably so
used that along with the utility and
privacy have to actually balance the
degree of interaction of the devices if
you want to deploy any of the learning
algorithms with privacy in practice and
this is not a story I just built up for
this talk so the motivation of the whole
direction of research came from my time
at Apple after we deployed the the
private heavy hitters algorithm for
Apple the next thing was to do
distributed private machine learning
with local differential privacy so it
was it was a task given to me and they
said like they're a paper so why don't
you implement those we started thinking
about it and my answer to them was that
in all honesty I cannot direct you to do
that work and we actually did not ship
that like we did not even pursue doing
the engineering because I realized that
our understanding of that whole space
was limited and that basically kind of
gave this direction of research so so
this comes from like purely from
engineering standpoint so what is this
talk about will show some new protocols
that are almost completely parallel
which gets optimal accuracy and the
local privacy model and some
impossibility results showing that you
need some degree of interaction with the
devices
I'll get into a bit more detail so what
is an ideal scenario if I'm a designer
algorithm designer well he's devising
tracks to the server in dependency and
only once so how the device decides a
bunch of questions server decides a
bunch of questions sends to the devices
devices respond back to the server with
the responses and done
this is amazing because you communicate
to the device only once and you do it
completely parallely absolutely this is
an ideal scenario I would want an
algorithm which is completely non
adaptive completely parallel for obvious
reasons
however the state-of-the-art at least
before this paper was by do see Jordan
Wainwright where they did have this
property that you communicate with the
device only once but the algorithm was
completely adaptive in the sense you
talk to each other device in sequence
and you receive the message from the
previous device to decide on the
commission you last to the next device
how does it work the question get an
answer you get an answer and continues
and reproduce the module so so the
number of rounds of interaction is equal
to the number of devices and remember I
told you this five millisecond or like
the communication in milliseconds now if
you try to train any method any
reasonable learning method with this
under privacy it almost becomes
infeasible
okay this work is about distributed
private learning with local differential
privacy yes you described a particular
way of going about it but what what in
their derivation makes that an
impossibility fruit oh so we haven't got
to the impossible to show that this is
actually necessary problems it's
necessary to query receive it's very in
sequence no that's that is the later
part of the proof but I'm still I'll say
that yes this is necessary so first I
will show algorithm that will use little
or no adaptive interaction in particular
if you have learning problems which are
or DRM problems which are
one-dimensional or constant dimensional
you can do completely thoroughly without
any interaction but if you go slightly
higher dimensional regimes you would
require some degree of attack adaptivity
and the natural question is is it
necessary well the lower bound says that
you cannot get accurate and general
algorithms that use no adaptive
interaction activity is some sense
necessary
this is just to wake you up this is a
slide for linear regression just to say
what setup I'm working and I'm working
with the other basically a bunch of data
samples I have the empirical minimizer
and I want to algorithms which produces
a model theta plip where the empirical
loss is close to the best possible
empirical risk when they stop and not
focus on population risk I'm just
focusing on the empirical risk just for
simplicity and this is just a picture of
linear regression where the loss is
essentially squared loss so so this is
what we know in terms of upper bound if
you have one dimensional constant
dimensionally RN problems then you can
get the optimal exists risk which is one
over square root of n times epsilon
squared in the local privacy model with
zero adaptive interaction if you are
doing linear regression you get square
root of P over N epsilon squared with
zero adaptive interaction in our paper
we also have the lower bound which says
that for linear regression this is
actually tight so this was not known
earlier the lower bound is also named in
the paper for any protocol the linear
regression the ERM loss is this much and
this is tight and in particular we get
this with new adaptive interactions so
you should look at that
if you're dealing with generally and
problems with Lipsius loss which
basically means that the gradient of the
loss functions are bounded then you
would require square root of P over in
epsilon squared this is optimal correct
in time or in interaction which is mean
of the dimensions times log of N and
epson in epsilon squared upon the
dimensions let me parse this statement
in a bit if you're strong convexity you
can get the optimal accuracy with much
lower number of adaptive interactions
which is not kind of surprising so let
me pass this kind of weird expression if
you have convex optimization problems
typically your accuracy is given let's
say if you want to reach an error of
alpha in your optimization then you'd
require roughly around P Times log of 1
over alpha around some interaction or 1
over alpha squared whichever is smaller
this essentially is the same symptom
given the accuracy you can reach is
square root of P over N epsilon squared
why am i saying this this comes from
purely optimization literature and with
differential privacy what you can do is
you can reach the same level of accuracy
without hurting the rate at which you
reach the tacit level of accuracy
some sense differential privacy does not
affect the rate of convergence up to
there so it will saturate there does it
kind of make sense
so these are the upper bones and we'll
show that like for this to class is a
problem you need some degree of
interaction in particular later work
after arts which are we showed that this
is actually necessary so the degree of
interaction is actually tight in terms
of lower bound so what we show is that
to achieve an excess empirical risk of
alpha any gradient based method that
makes at most 2 raised to the power of
small of the number of dimension queries
with the gradient Oracle needs to make
at least Omega of log of 1 over alpha
adaptive interactions with the data so
this was our lower bound you can
actually improve this I'll show in a bit
again P the number of dimensions
parameters
it okay so we know that the gradient
based methods are much weaker than LTP
then why why this lower bound all the
people Oh
so this is just this is a lower bound
for LD productions grading best methods
there is just four billion based methods
and in fact this lower bound is
independent of LDP protocols this is
just a lower bound for optimization
problems when I say for linear
regression the accuracy lower bound not
the adaptivity load so how does this
lower bound work I will go into much
more detail later on but typically the
idea is that we'll construct pairs of
function which will be different inside
a small regime and they will be
identical outside so basically if you
start throwing darts at the board you
have a very low probability of hitting
this ball but once you get the
information about what what the value of
the gradient or the function from this
dart then that will tell you what the
ball is and that round of interaction
would allow you to go inside this wall
so you this kind of will enforce so at
least one round of adaptivity so you
should go much more detail into it
so this is the lower bound so there are
new lower bounds which basically says
that that log of 1 over alpha was not
tight you can actually extend it to me
no 1 over Alpha squared and P resting
for 1/3 P is a number of dimensions if
you look at this term 1 over alpha
squared this is essentially what
gradient descent allows you to get so if
you're not in if your dimensionality
sufficiently high then essentially
gradient descent is the best what you
can achieve
and
the version of the result from BS 18
essentially is a adaptive inter
interpretation of the classic
nemirovsky routine lower bound so if you
look at the original numerous skewed in
lower bound for grading based methods
essentially you can do some surgery on
the low the the function which they
construct you actually get an adaptive
version of it and essentially this paper
does this modification to the new
manav's util you all want to get one
over alpha squared so all this is saying
is that gradients and best method is the
best you can do sorry mr. bush paper is
BS 17 this is your on single and balance
key
so this is description of the previous
work the cleanest paper introduced the
problem of local private learning duty a
tall give title tight upper and lower
bounds and accuracy which resulted in an
algorithm but the number of adaptive
interaction was equal to the number of
devices and this was some of the work
that was done on the applied front of
things and essentially while doing this
work the whole problems basically we
landed up in this problem and that kind
of gives positive and negative results
for us so it's kind of interesting that
pure engineering problem lands up in
research questions and this I'm not
making out
hopefully I have given you some kind of
motivation to stick around for the
algorithm and lower bounds so let's go
into that super simple problem
let's do single parameter learning P is
1 and here I'll promise to you that we
can do single parameter learning with no
adaptivity and we'll have some new ideas
showing that okay
this algorithm is kind of cute so
high-level idea is we'll reduce the
problem of ARS to finding median is it
I just wait for five seconds if it seems
obvious to you great if it doesn't next
few slides will tell you why it is kind
of interesting medium
we went a little samples you are
training young model with local
differential privacy for one-dimensional
problems and we'll do some surgery and
we'll transfer it into finding median of
a bunch of data samples how do you do
that first of the vision is that you
have a convex function the derivative of
the function I will talk about the
derivative because I'm dealing with one
dimensional function the derivative is a
monotone meaning it's a non decreasing
function right which essentially means
that I can represent the derivative as a
convex combination of a bunch of step
functions
now you should start getting a sense of
how this translates to a median now what
I will do is I will take my convex
function the loss function on the data
sample and do an approximation which
will be essentially a convex combination
of bunch of absolute value functions
because the derivative of an absolute
value function is just a function so
what I am doing is just a functional
approximation
the important point is it is a convex
combination
now what I will do
and for each of the data sample I'll
take my loss you like it in this convex
combination of absolute value functions
and then what I will do is I will just
sample a function or absolute value
function with probability that is given
by the value in the first nomination
ci is that like I told you write an
approximate this loss function as the
conviction of national punch of absolute
value functions so this is the center of
this absolute value functions
let's go back in a bit so I have yeah so
yeah but you have the loss function so
the loss function can be written as a
convex combination of absolute value
functions an each absolute value
function is centered at Z one till Z K
so what I'm doing is I'm putting a net
on the range space from minus 1 to plus
1 and at each of the net point I am
putting absolute value function so easy
just like the empirical risk minimum for
a single device no these the minimum for
the absolute value function it is a
point by the function is it matter how
the case will parameter you will
optimize that later yes then each point
person will do this approximation on her
device
so now you get a bunch of absolute value
functions
once you sample with the with the the
conversatio parameter and essentially
you get a bunch of absolute value
functions what are the what are the vs
well whatever that should value function
is it sample V is basically the sample C
and now it is about finding the median
of a bunch of data points V now this is
about find equivalent to finding the
median of a bunch of data points yes
yeah so this all depends on data sample
and this is super important that this is
done on the device so and the claim is
that by doing this kind of surgery you
are not introducing additional error
beyond what LDP would force you to
introduce now once you now the problem
is much simpler I forget my loss
functions I forget everything each
device has a data point and I want to
find out the median of the data points
how do you do that well this is how the
picture looks like
median is basically the minimizer of
this loss function so just put alpha net
on the space then what you do represent
each of the absolute value function with
the slopes the slope only channel
translates from zero to minus one to
plus one at some point right for each of
the absolute value function good so I'll
just break it up into two parts
well one part goes from minus one to
zero and other part goes from zero to
plus one so basically the slope changes
from minus one to plus one so I will go
from minus one to zero and zero to plus
1
and let's now look at and the the most
important point is if the server from
each of the devices knows this
information it can find out the median
because derivatives of the function will
give me by the median lease so all that
translates to is now I have to give a
differentially private way or LDP way of
sending this particular in function of
the step function what I will do is I
will hammer it with the binary tree
aggregation protocol by DNP r10 and
essentially what happens is like you see
that this function changes from zero to
one in one place so this is literally
one bit of information here and you
essentially use the binary tree
aggregation to kind of send out the
prefix terms so how much it I do you
incur by doing this well it is like
block one over alpha by epsilon or not
and you'd get two since there are log of
one over alpha nodes you needn't go to
log of three over two
so now what you do is the server
essentially aggregates this
differentially private versions of the
step functions and uses that to find out
the median so so notice that what I did
I could have approximated each of the
loss function by a net what I did is
approximately the derivatives by the net
if you have to leave work out the math
just by putting a net on the function
space you would not get optimal error so
to get to that one over 210 ever you
need to do this derivative space look at
the formal accuracy guaranteed under
appropriate choice of the alpha net you
would get around 1 over square root of n
of certainty and this is take
now a natural question that arises like
if I can extend this kind of a technique
to higher dimensions up to constant
dimension you may be a bit happy but
beyond that know the accuracy guarantee
will go exponentially worse with a
number of dimensions because a natural
way to do it is like first put a choose
a random direction and try to optimize
in that direction but your accuracy will
obviously be worse as you go in the
number direction because the poly
becomes more so this does not work
although you in higher dimensions you
can get an optimal accuracy of square
root of P over N epsilon squared using a
combination of two methods one is
definitiely private variant of the
gradient descent method we all know that
like if you take the gradient that noise
and do a bunch of iterations then you
would get a differential private
algorithm the variant we actually
analyzed in this paper is what is called
the cutting plane method it's basically
a binary search in the high dimensional
space the choice of the algorithm is not
that important but it has an important
message behind it we know that if you
are training differentially private
methods the dependence on dimensionality
is unavoidable
if you are doing just pure convex
optimization if you are ready to pay or
dependence in dimensionality then you
can get what they call linear
convergence meaning that you can cut to
go to an error of alpha you require log
of 1 over alpha rounds but there is a
dependence on the dimension see like
deep P Times log 1 over alpha if you
want to get completely independent
dimension in the end result you get to
gradient descent this is 1 over alpha
squared but the fact that differential
privacy would force you to have a
dependence on dimension there are
regimes where the this kind of binary
search or cutting plane methods are
better than red in the sense that we're
dealing with differential privacy which
also means that you have to do an
analysis of particular method not super
hard but one has to do it
so that's about algorithms
okay coming to the lower ones
since this talk was prepared in 2017 you
will get a steel version of the lower
bound then newest and the best world one
we should look at the paper but the
ideas are somewhat similar so what I am
trying to do is I am trying to show that
you would require some degree of
adaptivity to get to an error of alpha
and this lower bound is independent of
differential price these are purely
optimization lower bound so if you are
not allowed to make exponential number
of queries in the dimensions to the
function or the function or directive
then you need to make at least one of
our alpha norms of adaptive interactions
with the data before you actually go to
an error of alpha so how does this work
I will construct a function which would
behave as follows so to go to to reach
an error of alpha near optimization you
need to be in the small ball in the
whole space
No
so that I'm being just forget about the
pink and the green ball no if you're
trying to optimize the function what you
can do is you can just throw darts on
the space and evaluate the function
right okay
by throwing darts at the space the
probability of hitting this small ball
is very little now if I have two
functions which are identical in the
outer space and differ slightly in the
within the ball then just by throwing
darts at the space you will not be able
to figure out which function you are
dealing with
and then this you can do it recursively
basically you could construct the
function in a sequence where once by
throwing the darts oh sorry one thing I
need to say once you throw the darts at
this pace unless you see the answers to
those darts it won't know where even
this ball lies but once you see the
answer you look at the ball lines and
you can go the next query can be inside
the ball and that can help you tease
apart the two functions but whatever
done in this process I've enforced one
round of adaptivity you have to see the
answer before you know what the ball is
why to make the next query
and this construction you can do it
recursively but the problem with this
type of construction is that if you do
it recursively in your space reduces
exponentially because the volume kind of
the walls reduce exponentially and hence
you can do it up to log of 1 over alpha
rounds now an interesting question is
what did I say I will construct a pair
of functions which are slightly
different within a ball and identical
outside and these functions have to be
convex the homework exercise for your
class this is a good exercise to give
how this pair of functions the answer to
it is like super simple but it's kind of
a trick just before I go into that
construction of the function so prior
lower bounds numerous cubed in was non
adaptive lower bound but this recent
paper BS 18 essentially shows that you
can translate that into an adaptive
lower bound Nestor of 2004 proved a
lower bound for for gradient descents
type methods for the number of
adaptivity iran's of adaptivity but he
made a crucial assumption which said
that then then the points over which you
are making the gradient calls have to be
in the span of the gradients which you
have seen so far which is typically true
for gradient descent not for privately
descent because you are dealing with a
noisy process so you will not line the
span so in particular both of this lower
bound as its do not apply to that active
case it's just one query per round but
it's a sequential lower bound is a
sequential lower bound
okay so the challenge is that and to
clear to do this lab on the challenges
that you have to construct two functions
F and G that are same outside of set C
and differs significantly inside that
silk and these are convex functions
any thoughts
to significantly mean like they should
be for the minimus should be for you
so I'll choose a function f zero which
is basically the absolute value function
and according the higher dimensions they
will do I'll choose another pair of
functions F minus 1 and F plus 1 let's
say one is centered at Z minus 1 and
then this is similar to C 1 and their
slopes are lower than the center
function
we know that max of two functions is max
up to Congress function is always a
convex function so now once I do this in
this regime the yellow function
dominates over the blue function but
outside this regime the blue function
starts dominating so now my function
construction would basically
the first function would be max of F 0
and F minus 1 so have this pivot
function and reconstructive 0 and f
minus 1 there's a max of it is the other
function would be M 0 and F 1 so these
two functions differ in this regime and
they're identical outside this region
because that is dominated by f 0 and
these are convex functions
well you can use this essentially - this
pretty much gives util
so almost done with my talk so so in
this talk what I showed you is like new
algorithms that use little or no
adaptive interaction some lower bound
which says that you cannot get accurate
and general algorithms that use no
adaptive interaction if you are using
reading best methods if you don't use
that maybe you can achieve it
maybe you cannot but the lower bounds
what we have is for reading based
methods and I have some comments about
the open problems so I told you that if
you want to get the optimal algorithm
for like general Yellin problems in the
local model with the best round of
adaptivity you will use either a mix of
cutting plane or gradient descent method
well cutting plane is a meta algorithm
essentially results to finding out the
center of gravity of a weird convex body
which we do not know to find as is so
there are variants in the non private
world
the question is do they extend into the
private world something like by there's
algorithm and things like that there is
one question so can we actually have an
implementable algorithm for cutting
plane with differential privacy so so
the adaptivity lower bounds what we have
are not specific to local differential
primes these are like generic lower
bounds for optimization the question is
are there are typically lower bounds
which are specific to local differential
privacy
the last question is not necessarily
about local differential privacy but
rather about general private erm is it
always true that definition privacy does
not affect the rate of convergence for
an erm so if you look at the proofs of
private gradient descent methods
essentially what if you kind of tease
apart the terms you will see that if you
increase the number of rounds
declarations you do not hurt accuracy
we'll just saturate but the rate at
which you go to the accuracy that is
achievable under differential privacy is
the rate at which you have gone to that
accuracy even without privacy go like 1
over square root of T the question is is
it always true
[Applause]
yeah
so your your lower bounce as well as the
subsequent lower balance assume that the
gradient Oracle is giving you exact
gradients right the deccan is giving you
exact radiance is there are there any
potential stronger lower bounce that you
can get from a gradient Oracle that's
giving you noisy gradients and some
noise model for actually and that's
where this friend of the the open
question is like under it
okay no more questions let's
[Applause]